the reason why
i wanted to move it into a van was
because knowing how much it's annoyed me
over the years
people trying to get me on their podcast
i just like had a lot of resistance to
bringing that question to people myself
so i thought if i put it all into a van
then just say hey you know whenever and
wherever it's convenient for you we'll
just show up you hop in it's going boom
get out we'll make it so
easy for you so the idea of a portable
studio
was it's
and you're like [ __ ] i think this will
work for podcasts like this format
i'm so glad that you mentioned bang bus
because back in the day
thank god you mentioned bang bang but
yeah i mean think about this let me run
this by all
what's bang bus i just i'm just kidding
i'm gonna run something by all of you
guys right now you tell me if my theory
is correct
okay okay prostitution is
illegal okay but what if
on the bang bus you've got an ordained
minister
so you get on the bus you pick out a
lady
and you ask that lady to marry you now
the ordained minister officially marries
you so now you are
husband and wife you consummate the
marriage
on the bus and then when you're done
having sex then you think the better of
it and in all the marriage
and then you get off the bus once again
unmarried
have i not just legalized prostitution
well do you pay her at some point
i mean i think that annulling the
marriage i think that out of respect
you might want to uh have some kind of a
settlement yeah you want a
divorce settlement yeah i think you've
come up with your show it's like some
combination
judge judy i mean you gotta get a judge
in there
you know so it's like right you could
have a contentious divorce who knows
how how does that idea come about like
steve's like like
watching you know bang bus he's like
dude i would marry that chick and then
he busted that he's like
nah i wouldn't want to marry that
chicken think about that
i don't know i just thought i mean i i
think that i think that my
my [ __ ] theory holds water dude i
really do
yeah i do i think you figured it out
like for sure and why does that have to
be limited to a bus i mean
you could have a bra it could be like a
conveyor belt where like
phase one you get married then you just
slide along you bang and then you slide
along to divorce court
i mean talk about the vegas chapel i
mean right dude
like i just got to move it over to reno
i like that
cool afternoon
[ __ ] you go through a bad divorce
yeah that's a roller coaster of a day it
could be a roller coaster
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because
it's gnarly and it's all the stuff i
wasn't allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats